hello everyone welcome thank you for
tuning in for middle ground which is all
about disagreeing and having a dialogue
that's right make sure you stick around
to the end because we want to discuss
more about the ethos middle ground but
for now we hope you enjoy you said that
women are misguided we are not misguided
we do not need you to Shepherd us
[Music]
hello I would yes an intersectional
feminist Marxism to me feminism is
fairness I think that it's unfortunately
misguided feminism is a flow of
movements aggression advocating for the
human rights of man as a class I start
laughing I would hope to get some
insight and probably if anything agree
on a lot more than disagreeing I
actually hope to get a little bit more
understanding of why some men think this
way we'll see
[Music]
hi my name is Zach and I am 24 years old
this is Chris I'm a PhD student at the
University of Southern California
and I'm also titled my specialist who
challenges discrimination against men on
college campuses and I'm 30 years old
hi I'm Derek I'm school by brendi oh I'm
youtuber and I also muscle noticin in
cell which is an involuntarily celibate
hi my name is Alicia I am a writer poet
and teaching artist
hi I currently work in the pet health
industry and I'm 30 I'm 24 I'm a
graduate student with a degree in Health
Sciences and I'm excited to be here
today
I know as a woman that I don't have the
same physical strengths men and women
are built differently I think whenever
things are built differently it's for a
reason right but at the same time the
amount of limits that have been put on
women historically like the fact that
not too long ago we were just allowed to
like start voting even today like the
wage gap just all types of stuff like
women just don't have a lot of rights
that are just it should have nothing to
do with what gender we are to be able to
be paid equally or just be treated with
respect so yeah I do believe that of
course there are biological differences
between men and women and of course
there should also be legal equality of
course I disagree with the idea that
women face systemic discrimination you
just mentioned the wage gap which has
been debunked so many times I've studied
evolutionary biology quite a bit and men
and women are very different from not
just a physical you know the bone
structure the neurological department as
well as well as the chemical balances
and also I don't believe that men and
women are equal under the law either
they should be rather children are not
equal under the law and it's not because
we hate children it's because we love
them and we want to protect them so if
you believe we're not equal then that
you're inferring that one would be
greater than the other so let me let me
so that's right yes as far as not being
equal I don't think that that
necessarily means inferior or superior
when it comes to certain things like
roles like childbearing a woman is going
to be far more productive and a lot more
nurturing than say a man and when it
comes to doing a lot more of the heavy
lifting and the work a man is probably
going to be more suited for that role
and I don't think that that makes them
any better or worse we are just built
created and born different I would also
like to elaborate I am NOT saying that
they are worse overall or better overall
they complement you said yeah they do
complement each other you know to flee
if they worked very well together we
need each other for working their
offspring I mean that that's just that's
part of the beauty of it and I think
trying to equalize them and make them
the
same and you know transition and all
that I don't believe is going to be the
most conducive when it comes to the fan
went raising children but also just for
overall well-being I want to note that
you brought up children being unequal to
adults I just hope you weren't comparing
women to children I mean I it was
technically a comparison okay I don't
need you to protect me I just need you
not to harm me I can protect myself I'm
very capable of doing what I need to do
okay okay sure 100% I am a in cell or an
in cell advocates I suppose I don't hate
women at all I just I think we're
different and they have aspects that are
superior to men as well it's just very
contextual on the on the subject I think
that toxic masculinity is definitely a
real thing it's kind of just the idea of
what masculinity should be but it goes
wrong a lot of the times saying that
violence sex power being a controlling
person makes you a man I see it in very
unfortunate places like when the young
men were boys in my family even from
like toddler age are told you shouldn't
be crying boys don't cry and what that
turns into I see it when I'm in a
bookstore and a guy who tries to get my
number says why y'all always got to act
like that and he sincerely had this like
cracking voice like he was hurt but it
was an entitlement and that's toxic
masculinity it's saying like you don't
realize how your behavior is harmful
what does toxic masculinity mean is it
character traits is it upbringing the
suppression of feeling for a lot of men
because throughout childhood they're
told man up so because of that there's a
lot of repression repression then is
usually channeled into anger for some
people because they don't not always
know how to express because they're
totally not to express so upbringing and
that's part of it okay but not something
that's inherently far down of men no I
think that you know when you're showing
your emotions especially to like you
know random people random women in some
cases they will view you as weak I was
raised by a single mother I love her
she's a few no she's my mom I love her
but I could have used being told to to
act like a man I think back there were
some cases where I was too emotional and
that negatively affected how I you know
what happened to me may I ask a question
sure what is your definition of weak as
a man um not being as forward as you
could be not being as honest or you know
trying to be not as emotional as you
don't need to be you know you don't have
to cry over a cut I know you know
sometimes cuts hurt a lot but sometimes
it's necessary to be strong for the
benefit of not just yourself but for the
people around you you know it's fine to
to act emotional in certain cases but I
don't think it's fine to act that way
with a woman maybe you know you have a
really good friend and he sees you cry
like her you know your best friend and
you're crying about something really
personal I think that's fine feel like
you're completing two different
situations because you started off with
saying random person or even women so it
feels like okay this is a woman that you
don't have a bond with or any type of
relationship with and then you mentioned
or from your best friend you know that's
okay to cry well that woman could be
your best friend that you know like what
so and again a woman so because you
don't see us as equal as you said before
I don't think showing emotions is a sign
of weakness I actually thinks it's a
sign of strength men do live shorter
lives and that's because of a repression
of emotions and that's due to many
things that patriarchy has instilled it
has been shown that a person's
well-being their life span is shortened
when they are not able to express their
emotions in addition when they don't
have physical touch or when they don't
have a partner to keep them company
we're human beings here we need to talk
to each other and if you think that our
health isn't affected when you're not
able to express that you're sad or upset
you're wrong
I think that men's rights activists are
only men's rights activists as a
response to women expressing that they
want more equality I don't think they
focus on actual men's rights issues and
rather it's just an attack on women and
feminism
I can speak from a hiring standpoint on
when it comes to things like affirmative
action and there are certain rules that
that traditionally men and women have
been able to serve in and now women can
basically do all of those things right
because we've had such a strong advocacy
for equal representation in the
workplace whereas for example you know
you'll never find a man as a midwife
nurse and I don't think it's appropriate
that's why there are those differences
women like the most important parts of
society have an advantage there's a lot
of positions that men simply aren't
getting hired at anymore because of you
know the fact that they're a man and
it's not just in in in in the workforce
it's also I would say you know it's a
lot easier for a woman to to find a
relationship even if she you know says
it's awesome finding the right guy is so
hard it really isn't but the fight
sometimes for a lot of guys finding a
girl at all is hard if I have to
consider what I wear before stepping out
the house because I don't want to draw
some type of attention I don't know how
many other men have to consider is this
outfit going to be condemned safe for me
any situation that I have experienced
where like I physically felt endangered
simply because I don't want to give my
number out it's part of that entitlement
for men you're not entitled a
conversation when you're not entitled to
my number that aside it's like are you
gonna make one example of the
entitlement of men when it comes to
asking for your number be the
all-encompassing thing that all men have
a problem when it comes to approaching
women well firstly it's not just an
example it's not necessarily all men I
don't dislike men I love sports I play
video games I have bros I hang out with
dudes
we just want men to realize that if you
have friends that are having locker room
talk as a man as an ally please say
something to your friends do you think
we're pressing that is really the
solution here though if it's a healthy
male space
I don't think that's healthy I think
it's again it's Ellen if you're making
jokes and you're doing all jokes that
are harmful jokes are not healthy
because they just lead to people
normalizing things people always say oh
it's just a joke but when someone else
hears it they don't realize how that
resonates and again how that turns into
violence like this is not an isolated
situation I'm only thinking of three off
the top of my head because if I think of
too many it's gonna I'm gonna spawn so
what's the alternative
men shouldn't talk about these things no
I think men have a healthy dialogue I
don't think men have to be toxic in
order to have a conversation I know
plenty of men that are able to have
conversations about healthy productive
productive things just like women are
well it's not obviously something that I
have personal experience with but only
1% of all people on the d'être are women
in this country so when women and men
commit identical crimes women are much
more likely to for example escape the
death penalty and that's just plain
sex-based discrimination I agree on
that's true look I'm thinking about
basic needs like around the globe the
women who don't even have like proper
like sanitary like products I mean I
have to agree to small things like
attacks on a box of tampons do you think
I choose to do this monthly no trust me
so why should I have to pay taxes when
this is a medical necessity it should
we're just like dismissed a lot of our
symptoms a lot of the things we report
especially women of color but women
across the board are just treated a lot
less equally I'd say that I'm an
advocate for what I believe the role
that men play in society I believe that
their views should be expressed openly
that they should be given a platform to
do so and I believed in men
unapologetically and unashamedly being
men as we were created I think in my
heart that there are things that men are
entitled to I am all about human rights
and I try to consider I do consider the
rights of every human but
every time I hear of a men's rights
activists I hear anger and I hear very
illogical reasoning and it just boils my
blood because it's a setback for all of
us I think a lot of times when a
movement is created the other side
thinks that they're being attacked or
think that it's some like attempt at
erasure that's not what feminism is
about at all what do you need a whole
men's rights activism movement for I'm
sincerely confused well I mean like I
will advocate for positive masculinity
and what men should represent and
healthy outlets for men like I still
think the Boy Scouts should be
exclusively the Boy Scouts for example
one of those things where I would like
to think that we could get some common
ground is when it comes to the clear
biases that are in the court system
especially in the marriage and family
court system right and and right there
is what I would advocate for when it
comes to men's rights the things that
stand Valli like that I'm hearing from
y'all that are like violet to me come
from a place of like I am treated like
unfairly by the system versus a lot of
the things women are saying it's also
America and a system as well but a lot
of is like harm from men
how and where how and where what where's
this harm from men coming okay it
started when I was young I'm not gonna
talk too long I was 16 got a bottle
thrown at me because I told her boy I
know it started when I was in a club a
boy touched me I said no he kept
touching me got to the point he got
violent he gets to the point that the
only reason why a man decided to stop
touching me in the bookstore I talked
about earlier is because he realized my
husband was not too far away he said
sorry bro never said sorry to me that's
why and that's off the top of my head
this is why I get upset because I'm like
I'm here to talk about like how you feel
but when you just dismiss the fact that
women actually have experiences that's
when it seems like it's about more than
your rights it seems like it's about
your ego and that's where I get pissed
off not where you tell another human
being that their experiences what
they're telling you right in front of
your face is not valid I didn't say they
were invalid
said how and why I'm trying to
understand why because it happened it
happened many times it happened
yesterday okay I think some of the
things that you guys are touching on
such as the court system and gender
roles are a subject of patriarchy and
that's part of what women are trying to
dismantle is those traditional gender
are there is a feminist organizations
that have done anything for example to
challenge bias against men and fathers
and yeah of course can you please give
me like a list of feminist advocacy
organizations that have engaged in any
meaningful advocacy they are just those
issues because they are actually none
okay
I know that you came with your little
research or whatever I didn't come with
a list of like feminist organizations
but I know actively that there are
women's organizations that are trying to
dismantle those injuries just one name
just one again somewhat the list my dude
there are no such organizations I think
that has been significant progress over
the last decade or so especially in the
legal field but I think there are still
significant disparities that need to be
addressed such as poor health conditions
bias against men in the criminal justice
system bias against men in family courts
and a bias against men in the
educational system especially in
colleges men unfortunately many of them
don't want to even have this open
dialogue that we're sharing right now we
need men to help be allies to help speak
to other men it strikes me like the way
you phrase this you almost want men to
say certain things that you want them to
say I supposed to maybe actually
listening that what they're saying is
just kind of like men being allies men
talking each other men had cetera I'm
completely ok with that but I'm not
going to repeat like feminists talking
points to other men we all believe
different things we may be under the
label of men's rights activists but for
example I'm probably the most
traditionalist person here I think we
should be allies but maybe us being
allies in a patriarchy wouldn't be so
bad
you know us going back to the past
wouldn't be so bad it would probably be
a lot happier
we were you know getting married and
staying married and having kids and you
know going to church and all that
well speaking the three of you I feel
like there are your each coming from
different perspectives so it's hard to
you know again just like the FEM are our
perspectives it's hard to generalize so
to me I feel like there are certain
things that even though we're not fully
agreeing on it where things may get lost
in translation or verbage they may not
be high percent correct that we could at
least agree on can I ask one question
what would you envision would be the
ideal man with the end goal of feminism
as far as educating men or working to
dismantle whatever patriarchy is like
what what does that man look like it
starts with childhood we have to teach
children as well as girls because we're
also taught because of toxic masculinity
what are what a man should be as well I
think that we just need to hold men
accountable in order to kind of make
progress we need help from people that
will listen because let's be real when
we express our concerns a lot of men
refuse to listen but they would be more
likely to listen to another man do you
also feel like you have an ethical
obligation to challenge other women or
other feminists men for example they
deny that men face discrimination when
it comes to things like oh man can't be
abused I've actually have had this
conversation with another woman and it's
the idea that just because I mean maybe
physically stronger than us does not
mean they cannot be abused and because
of that again fairness women need to be
held accountable as well I want to
understand their viewpoint as a woman
and a woman of color I know how it feels
to be disenfranchised so I want to
understand why they feel the need to
have a men's right movement
I don't think there's ever a time in my
life for a person says they're hurting
and I don't at least try to listen or
understand my only thing is that I want
the same in return so when I'm genuinely
saying I'm hurting or I've been through
something and it's not just a personal
experience because I actively do this
work I surround myself with women saying
I've been hurt by a man before I get
that you have stories but I mean that's
actually my question I haven't heard
y'all stories like I've set up here and
said I have three on the top of my head
I have about 30 plus roughly and I
haven't heard y'all say this is what
happened to me I don't think that I'll
ever invalidate a woman's feelings when
she says hey I've been abused or whatnot
I don't think any of us here are
rightfully saying that but I think
what's dangerous is when emotional
testimony that may not always be what it
is gets you know creates bias right okay
I feel empathy for women being lost
being this guy look mm I don't know
outlets you can go do you have any bit
of empathy for anybody said yes I really
do feel a bit evil why was that so hard
to say like for the stuff that we said
you have any any bit of empathy for the
stories I say I do like I'm not even
trying to be hostile just generally want
to know yeah I just think they'd like a
lot of the problems that have happened
in your life are because society is not
patriarchal it's not traditional it's
it's we're gone we're lost
we we're gonna fall in states right
there is a change of guard not necessary
change of guard but things are evolving
things are changing and I feel like a
lot of men speak from a viewpoint almost
a fear a lot of men are having a hard
time grasping that and feeling
comfortable with it I do feel empathy
for your personal experience but I
cannot sympathize with your ideological
position because that ideological
position is built on a fallacy and a
fallacies actually cost
like very that's causing very real
consequences for men as a class in this
country so I understand that you are
here with us it's kind of the good
feminist so to speak that you feel
empathy for men and I believe you but I
do not believe you're a movement and I
do not believe your ideology
[Music]
I'm sweaty you are very articulate are
you okay that was interesting John what
do you think it means to disagree
thoughtfully I think when you disagree
it's important to acknowledge the other
side's opinion and to kind of respect
that opinion and to know that maybe you
can't change it and I think like we've
had a lot of middle ground where people
stick to their sides but they at least
acknowledge and try their best to
understand where the other person is
coming from and sometimes I think that's
the best we can ask for well we want to
hear from you all to let us know about
you know something that you may have
agreed with or disagree with we want to
see the same type of meaningful dialogue
in the comments below we'll be looking
out for those as always make sure you
leave a comment like subscribe I'll see
you guys next time
[Music]